taking a turn now we have surprising new
information from the special grand jury
in Georgia that investigated the former
presidents uh president Trump's alleged
effort to change the state's 2020
election results the Four Women of that
grand jury she is breaking with the
usual practice and talking in public
about the jury's recommendations Robert
Costa is in Georgia with more on this
Robert very unusual turn of events good
morning
it is good morning Tony The Fulton
County district attorney has not yet
announced whether she will pursue
charges against former president Donald
Trump but the four woman for this
special Grand Jury has now hinted that
the special Grand Jury has recommended
indictments for more than a dozen key
players
it's not a short list Emily Coors the
four woman on the special grand jury
investigating former president Trump's
alleged interference in the 2020
election results in Georgia is speaking
out her interviews come unusually before
the district attorney has announced how
to proceed it also follows a judge's
partial release of a report last week on
the special Grand jury's findings which
states that jurors believe one or more
witnesses might have lied during
testimony if they been following the
investigation
I I can't see it being a shocker much of
the probe centered around the alleged
pressure campaign led by former
president Trump and his longtime lawyer
Rudy Giuliani on Georgia officials like
Secretary of State Brad raffensberger
who Trump pressed in a January 2021
phone call
Brad I have them the grand jury also
looked into allegations that the former
president was involved in a plan to roll
out fake presidential electors in
Georgia while Coors stoked intense
speculation she would not explicitly say
whether the special grand jury is
recommending charges against Trump her
comments about private grand jury
deliberations are rare and come after a
judge decided to keep several sections
of its report secret we definitely heard
a lot about former president Trump and
I'll say that uh when this list comes
out you wouldn't
they're no major plot twists waiting for
you
sources close to former president
Trump's legal team tells CBS news they
are monitoring what the four woman has
been saying but they know at the end of
the day it's the district attorney who
will make the final decision on whether
to move forward former president Trump
continues to deny any wrongdoing and
this all comes as he's mounting his 2024
presidential campaign Gail
well the poor woman seems to have lots
to say thank you very much Bob